[Music]
look on the road that was a ygb
see mum saw a king anya is a rising star
on the uk rap scene
he's made a name for himself writing
music about his extraordinary life
but there's one subject in particular
that means more to him
than anything else there was one in
particular he kept coming back
he was a cambridge dragon his name was
jack and roska says he owes his life to
jack merritt
who was killed one year ago in the
london bridge terror attack
he relives that day so
i was on my way to the event i'll go to
the bridge i could see the
so you were meant you were meant you
were due to be on london bridge to see
jack that day
and um i get to the bridge and this
completely mayhem
it's locked off um my phone rings
and it's my probation and she's like
rosco
kings are trying to get hold of you
because they want to find out where you
are
i'm like i'm out of bridge um she's like
don't look at social media and i'm like
why don't she's like
don't worry about it don't look at
social media
i'll ring you soon and i'll tell you so
my intuition just told me something
bad's happened because i could clearly
see was
you know there's a lot of police there
and
i then start ringing around i get
through to one of my friends
from cambridge and um they didn't tell
me what
what happened and it was just like
they told you about jack yeah told me
about jack
told me about saskia told me about all
the other victims that was affected and
all the people that managed to survive
[Music]
and jack first met in prison roscoe was
serving a long sentence for carrying a
gun
and jack helped run the rehabilitation
program
i met jack through an intervention
course called learning together
yeah so learning together tend to focus
on
um bringing like cambridge students
into prisons and you all learn together
um which i thought was an amazing idea
but i didn't think that a time just to
be fake
in this in the song you say that you're
really nervous because i was gonna
i was so nervous you're the boy from
south london these posh cambridge grads
are coming in right and they don't even
like they don't understand my world
they wouldn't even you know where i come
from
we view people that go to cambridge or
oxford or
harvard or whatever as posh kids with
privilege
parents and all of that stuff but that's
not the truth the first moment i met
jack is when you walked through the room
so jack was bomber jacket
dr martins some nice trousers that came
up to by his ankles
um loopy earrings in his ears
um and a big massive smile for everyone
yeah anyone i shook hands with
so that was the first impression this
kid's very cool
like he's cool he stands out proper
stands out
the first thing how he brought the ice
with me and him he said
do you like rap music and i was like
yeah i rap i rap rap i've been rapping
from a young
from a young age and stuff then he
started breaking it down to me and
telling me about
other people's music careers and like
where they come from and
what they've been through and all this
stuff so
from then on that that was that was the
key like
all right cool so we both got passion
for music i like music you like music
so then he's like where'd you come from
and i'll come from the congo he's like
oh i know about the congo there's a lot
of war
and there's a lot of like of legitimacy
there's refugees and i was like
and i said i was a refugee and then then
it just kept going
okay so he just sort of unpeeled you
almost yeah like an onion
what jack did in his 25 years takes a
whole lifetime to come anywhere near
a fighter compassion is strong still
confusing
believing you're gone and there were
lots of layers for jack to peel
roscoe had a traumatic childhood caught
up in the civil war in the democratic
republic of congo
his parents were sent to prison he was
sent to a refugee camp
just five years old life wasn't easy
his older brother was murdered his
sister went missing
i was a very angry kid
because of the stuff that happened to me
and my sisters
you know um when you're in these camps
the the people that's meant to be there
to protect you and look after you and
and just you know not
keep you safe sometimes other people
that come in and do bad things to people
i.e women kids you know so that's the
soldiers that they put around the
perimeters and other people and you know
the the aid workers that come in there
there's a lot of
things that happen in these places that
you know um
a lot of people are unaware of and
yeah a lot of bad things happening in
places
rosco came to the uk when he was nine
and was reunited with his parents in
south london
unable to speak english and struggling
at school he became
prey for the gangs so there was this
group of
like older kids in the area yeah this
was in plumstead
at a time where i lived and they took a
liking to me and just
basically that's where it all went wrong
you know they recruited you into yeah
yeah like it started off by that can't
play football was
kicked me a ball all of that stuff so
any chance i had to get a house and say
oh i want to go and play football
outside i'll go downstairs because
i was just a lonely kid yeah yeah
because i wanted that sense of belonging
and fitting in yeah yeah
i kind of latched on to that so like 10
years old
yeah so i'm like 10 10 and a half going
on 11
waiting to start secondary school did
you realize what was happening at that
point or i mean you're a little kid
right you just think these guys are
honestly kind of being kind to you
honestly beth i thought that was the
best love i had at that point from
friends you know and that's just my
that's my truth because
the girls alone there was like 13 14 and
the boys was like 13 14 and i'm thinking
these are big kids and they're trying to
teach me little words of english and
whatever and they're pulling my cheeks
the girls are telling me how cute i am
and pulling my cheeks and stuff so i'm
like okay cool
so if these kids are showing me this
much love and they're much older
why can't kids at school be like this
and show me
show me love so i latched on to that
sense of belonging i was looking for
to the point where i went from there's a
car pulling up or
going drop that to that car at the time
i didn't even know what i was
just be totally honest with you but it
was drugs presumably yeah but as i grew
older
yeah you began i knew exactly what it
was but that time
it was too late yeah i was deep in i
fell in love with it
i fell in love with the sense of
belonging the security that i had
from from these pairs of people you know
i didn't fall in love with
the the selling drugs and doing other
things and all of that stuff like
yes when it they started paying me and
the money started coming in a little bit
i did think like well i'm getting money
i can go i used to go home and give my
sisters money like
take this for your lunch and you know um
another thing i always told myself i
made myself a promise when we came to
this country that
me and my sisters were never gonna go
hungry again
you know that's something that i i've i
i held deep in my heart like we are
never ever going to go hungry again
we're never going to starve we're never
going to go through we've been through
like i will try my utmost best to make
sure that you
are fair then you're you know you've got
what you need to
to have if i ever told you about the
things that i've seen all the place that
i've been
but it's grace i'm clean all this pain
in my heart more
time i can't sleep i can't breathe kind
of pain runs deep
let's take it back to the start i
remember by the age of 12 13 you're sort
of out of control right yeah um
at night time i used to climb out the
window
and just walk down the road for for as
long as i can
come on this is i can't sleep like i've
got all these things going on in my head
and we're talking like three o'clock and
i'm like
12. you know at this time i'm 12 and i'm
going through this all these things in
my head that i don't know
what it's called at a time yeah yeah and
i don't know it's trauma and i don't
know what's happening yeah
um having flashbacks and i'm just
getting out of the house and i'm just
walking and then i'll come back in at
some
mad hours pour my school blazer and go
to school
so i was just like what the hell is
happening to me you end up
getting convicted for carrying a firearm
right
but i also read i don't know if this is
right but that you you've been stabbed a
number of times is that right yeah
17 times yeah in total about
about 19 times that's just being
in the wrong areas at the wrong time you
know in south london and
people coming up to you and saying what
area you're from or being a
part of a people that you hang around
with which are gangs and
you know um yeah so i was in a coma for
three days
um i'm not i'm still lucky to be here
speaking to you
so you were in a coma yeah so you were
stabbed 19 times on different occasions
or at once
the 17 times was once you were stabbed
17 times that's when you're in a coma
yeah that's when i was in my corner yeah
and you
you nearly died yeah at that point
didn't you just think i need to get out
of this
and do and do where was i where would i
go
what would i do um
what am i going now what who am i going
to turn to
you know like how am i going to survive
how am i going to live am i going to
feed myself
you know you get all these things going
through your head
i mean a lot of people would be at the
time would have been pretty afraid of
you when you're a young man you think
yeah i wouldn't say that i was a
frightening young man i'll say
that i was a confused lost young man
they took jack from my heart now i'm out
here alone
roscoe was sent to prison for nine years
jack helped prepare him for his parole
hearing
you'll come in every now and then i'll
see him we'll talk and we'll be like
okay so how's your
how's things going i've got my parole
coming up okay so
you need to research this research that
and research this and
keep on this path that you're on and
you'll be okay yeah so when we didn't
get my parole
me him and one of our professors was in
a hallway on the wing
i was crying and jack started breaking
that jack started crying and my other
professor started crying from cambridge
in that moment i looked to them and i
thought
wow so you actually feel my pain
with me up until that point me and jack
was friends and we was
doing things and it was meant to me and
everything but the moment that he cried
for my pain because i was crying and i
was an emotional wreck
that's the moment that our bond became
even more stronger
you know
so is that when he went from friend to
brother for you yeah
because in that moment he showed me that
everything at ease
he wanted for himself he also wanted it
for me
if i said to you off your top of your
head like the first three
words that you would give to me to
describe jack what would they be it was
fair
it's a beautiful beautiful soul
um it was compassionate
okay thank you and a great brother our
ad daddy and because that's what he was
okay thank you thank you
you